[Music]
it is an unlikely place to find
Ukraine's war effort in full swing
in the bowels of a former Railway plant
five thousand miles from the
battlefields
American Steel Workers producing round
after round of artillery
we're on the production line of a
century-old factory
an industry that had been dismissed as
obsolete
is now in overdrive
this robot will operate in this
environment all day every day
the tour offered to Sky News is an
attempt to show that the production line
is fine that the West is not running out
of ammunition the U.S Army's boss here
is Richard Hansen
in production we're working in as hard
as we need
and probably two shifts every day solid
five six days a week also preparing you
know to increase production
incrementally
none of the officials will mention
Ukraine itself language is carefully
controlled contracts and meeting demand
but the contract is Ukraine and the
demand is huge
the flow has not been this fast since
the Korean War 70 years ago
eleven thousand rounds now roll off this
line each month and yet it's not nearly
matching what Ukraine's Army is using
well one staggering statistic which
illustrates the intensity of the war in
Ukraine the military there is firing off
between five and seven thousand of these
artillery shells every single day and
that's why the U.S military is investing
two billion dollars so ramp up
production of facilities like these
this Factory alone is getting 240
million dollars to modernize because
Russia has spooked the West a mechanical
War of the type they thought was in the
past it's firing up old factories and
old rivalries
Russia is
proud of what we do
we deciding to be a part of it
the pre-ukraine just-in-time supply
chain is breaking down and stockpiles
are shrinking but simply it's a race
against Russia to rearm it's expensive
important safety standards slow the
process and this is the easy part
because from here they're shipped a
thousand miles west to Iowa where
they're filled with explosives and fuses
are fitted and then to Ukraine
this surge in activity reflects the new
fragile reality hollowed out Western
stockpiles and the threat of Continental
conflicts
Mark Stone Sky News in Scranton
Pennsylvania